no host no problem tonight we celebrate
the art of storytelling the 92nd annual
Academy Awards kicked off on Sunday
night at the Dolby Theatre in Hollywood
with Janelle Monae bringing the house
down with her best mr. Rogers
[Applause]
neighbor
you'll be mine
yep we're talking red cardigan and all
as she's saying won't you be my neighbor
right - Oscar nominee Tom Hanks let's
make the most of this beautiful day
we're here at the Oscars so might as
well stay would you be mine could you be
mine
my neighbor and literally no one was
having more fun than Tom's wife Rita
Wilson be loud be seen be lit be heard
cus tonight we go
that's when Janelle hit the stage with a
bunch of dancers dressed in costumes
that represented some of the year's
biggest nominated flicks
[Music]
Billy Porter joined her on stage rocking
a blinged-out trenchcoat to sing Elton
John's I'm still standing and Janelle
gave a not-so-subtle shout-out to the
ladies in the house we celebrate all the
amazing talent in this room we celebrate
all the women who directed phenomenal
films yep Janelle straight-up called out
the lack of female nominees and so did
Chris Rock and Steve Martin who took the
stage after her they don't really have
hosts anymore why is that Twitter so
many great directors nominated this year
I don't know cause III thought there was
something missing from the list this
year vaginas yeah the comedian's also
address the lack of diversity vo is here
tonight yes
[Applause]
is here tonight Cynthia did such a great
job in Harriet hiding black people that
the Academy got her to hide all the
black nominees
there's any barfi under this stage ABC
Entertainment president Kari Burke
announced the Oscars were going without
a host back in January
saying it quote worked for us last year
adding they were going for huge
entertainment value big musical numbers
big comedy and star power post Lesage
kurz but how does that change the vibe
or what does that mean well it was you
know we did it last year as well and I
actually thought it worked
et caught up with Disney CEO Bob Iger
before the Big Show and he echoed those
same sentiments the show is just a
little bit quicker I think the pace is
better and I don't think we really
missed it when we look forward tonight
as dramatic moments surprises some great
heartfelt speeches a lot of humor
and you know hopefully I don't know not
too much lecture
[Music]